maybe oh wow bishop jesus unbelievable  yeah i was reading this in the chat that  bishop takes g6  uh was a move and i was calculating a  little bit  i guess the point is h takes g6  you can you have a few different options  you can start by taking on g6 but you  can also take on e6  now  the knights on a5 and b6 they are very  very far away from the action but oh my  goodness is this complex these  sacrifices yeah that's a brilliant idea  he just he just  improved our idea  but i'm very curious about that pawn  structure  very very curious about the pawn  structure and uh  because then you want to go behind the  pawn  oh wait oh yeah it takes an e7 no no it  was a mistake it's take on e7 maybe the  rook fell  take yeah  just somehow remove this pawn on c5  rook a7 king p6  yeah yeah yeah i is running out of ideas  yeah  he's done it so well i'm not saying  anything okay